[Music]
time now for final exam where our news
experts compete to see who is the best
ever calling the events that they cover
just this week this week's contestants
repaving staff writers the Federalists
and Fox News correspondent Griff Jenkins
which you can see has been gravely
injured in the pursuit of his duties as
a correspondent somehow we're not to ask
questions I hope you're okay Griff all
right great to see you both I am hosting
for an undisclosed location with the
judges present so if there's any
question at all they're right here
outside of camera shot to advise me you
know the rules but for our viewers our
homeland may not remember them they are
these hands on buzzers I asked the
questions the first one to buzz in gets
to answer the question you could wait
until you finish asking it before you
answer every correct answer is worth one
point each incorrect two tracks a point
from your total best of five wins are
you ready let's let's go perfect
question one which Swedish pop
supergroup just announced it is getting
back together after 35 years to make new
music but say they are unsure whether
their songs are any good a ba grift
the Swedish supergroup give it away
let's check the tape abba is making a
comeback awesome
[Applause]
the Swedish band announcing their
decision to release new songs and a
virtual tour after 35 years I can't
answer they're filled with self-doubt
look that we're not sure at music is any
good good job Grif Jenkins up one
question - this is a multiple choice
question Hillary Clinton found yet a new
group to blame for her loss in the 2016
election which group is it is it a the
Socialists B the vegans or C the Satanic
temple
those are good choices which group is
Hillary blaming I'm gonna go with this
realist you think she's blaming this
socialist I think she is yeah see if
you're right if you're in the Iowa
caucuses and 41% of Democrats are
socialists or self-described socialist
and I'm asked are you a capitalist and I
say yes you know that that probably gets
lost and though my gosh she's a couple
as she's definitely capitalist that's
pretty baby nice job so it's one to one
you versus the injured Grif Jenkins okay
question three nearly 10 years ago
George W Bush was making his farewell
visit to Iraq when a man you may
remember this took off his shoes and
threw them at President Bush the man who
threw those shoes is now embarking on a
brand new career what is it wait I could
guess that one but I would be if you
have to do some buzzer before guessing
it which is good arm I'm not gonna go in
go for it a new career for this shoe
thrower think about it what's a natural
correct there you go brie Payton I'm
gonna guess he's gonna be like a PE
coach or like a baseball Little League
something where he has to throw things
with children baseball coach Little
League something from the sporting world
where he has to throw things to the tape
we go
maaan solder Alzate he is a man that
took nine months in prison for deciding
on George Bush's farewell tour through
Iraq a place in which you were present
to pick up his shoes take them off his
feet and throw them at the president the
president showing great reactions he is
now going to be running for office in
case you are double decision he's
running for the Council of
Representatives you have a throwing
throwing question in there by the way
not to make you feel head trip the guy
is no self-control and he's badly
dressed a politician of course well
question for at an event this week the
French president had some trouble with
his English being French which word did
he accidentally use declaiming was
accidental to describe the wife of the
Australian Prime Minister delicious
Griff Jenkins
delicious I don't come on now that's
vulgar delicious is that really
delicious let's roll the tape I wanted
to thank you for your welcome sankiji
you and your delicious wife for one
welcome organization of this trip thanks
to you he's just French he means it
alright final question this wouldn't be
final exam without an animal question
it's tradition a video going around the
internet this week shows an Australian
man knocked off his paddleboard
vigorously by what variety of sea animal
dolphin a dolphin a dolphin dolphins a
hero nice for that let's see if the tape
proves you right
dolphin danger and these have a border
gets the surprise of a lifetime when a
dolphin
out of the waves and not into the lose
on a surfing question that's really hurt
it is exactly right
a dolphin that's and as a surfer you
know Grif that's unusual dolphins don't
do anything by accident they didn't like
that guy yeah Grif Jenkins you win two
to one breed did a fantastic job but I
know for sympathy sake you let Grif have
it and we're glad that was thank you and
if I were give you the the victory mug
when I see you next week
Grif Jenkins prepaid that's it for this
week's final exam tune in carefully to
the news each and every day and till
next Thursday and see if you've
accumulated enough knowledge to beat the
experts we'll be right back
[Music]